hi i'm beau carnes with freecodcamp.org
in this course i will be teaching you
the basics of openstack and how to use
it openstack is an open source software
that provides cloud infrastructure for
virtual machines bare metal and
containers to follow along with this
course it can be helpful to have a basic
understanding of the linux command line
networking and virtualization but none
of that is required by the end of this
course you will have a core
understanding of what openstack is and
you will know the basics of setting up
and administering openstack using the
openmetal platform
you'll also understand some commonly
used openstack services
so let's talk more about what openstack
actually is openstack is an open source
cloud computing platform that is used by
organizations to manage and control
large-scale deployments of virtual
machines such as in a cloud computing or
virtual private server environment
openstack is a popular choice for
organizations because it's scalable
reliable and provides a high degree of
control over the underlying
infrastructure besides being used to
manage deployments of virtual machines
openstack can also be used to manage
storage and networking resources in a
cloud environment in some ways openstack
can be compared to aws but here are some
key differences between the two
openstack is an open source platform
while aws is a proprietary platform
openstack offers more flexibility and
customization options than aws openstack
typically requires more technical
expertise to set up and manage than aws
since you basically have to set up
everything yourself in the past
beginners had trouble getting into
openstack due to its complexity and
difficulty in being set up for smaller
teams
but new technology has come out to make
openstack available as a service which
opens up the door to this super powerful
open source cloud system this video can
be followed by beginner admins but
infrastructure focused people like
devops and system teams should find this
very valuable
let's go into more detail about what
openstack offers beyond standard
infrastructure as a service
functionality additional components
provide orchestration fault and service
management and other services to ensure
high availability of user applications
openstack is broke up into services to
allow you to plug and play components
depending on your needs
this openstack map shows common services
and how they all fit together
i'm not going to cover every service
here but let me tell you what some of
the more common openstack services do
openstack object storage or swift is a
highly scalable distributed object
storage system openstack block storage
called sender is a service for managing
block storage devices
openstack compute called nova is a cloud
computing fabric controller which
manages the allocation of compute
resources
openstack networking called neutron is a
system for managing networks and ip
addresses
the openstack dashboard which is called
horizon is a web-based interface for
managing openstack resources openstack
identity called keystone
is a system for managing user accounts
and access control openstack image
called glance is a service for storing
and retrieving virtual machine images
openstack bare metal called ironic is a
service for provisioning and managing
air metal servers so those are some of
the more common services and we'll be
demonstrating some of them later in this
course
there are a bunch of different ways to
deploy and configure openstack based on
the needs of your application or
organization
so we're about to learn how to get
started with openstack and use many of
the most common features
one of the easiest ways to get started
with openstack is by using the openmetal
on-demand private cloud this allows us
to quickly deploy openstack to the cloud
and simplifies the setup process
openmetal provided a grant that made
this course possible while we'll be
using openmetal to learn about openstack
the material covered in this course
applies to any openstack deployment not
just ones that use openmetal so no
matter how you want to use openstack
this course is for you and feel free to
leave a comment with anything that
you're learning or any questions you
have about this content
so let's look at how to set up openstack
on openmetal
to get openstack set up you need to
provision and set up your cloud on
openmetal
we'll just follow the prompts on this
openmetal central page to get everything
set up
during the setup process you're going to
have to enter a public ssh key
later when we went to ssh into one of
the cloud servers
the public private key pair will
basically act as our password or our
login information to ssh into the server
so to get a public ssh key there's a few
different ways but the most common way
is to go over to your terminal or your
command line
now this is going to work pretty similar
whether you're on windows mac or linux
there is a program called
ssh key gen
so if you just type in ssh key gen
it will generate a public private key
pair
now you
may have to install the ssh key gen
program on your computer but also it may
already be automatically installed
so i'm not going to go through the whole
generation prompts because i've already
generated it so
once you've generated it you're going to
have to get access to the private key
that you generated so i'm just going to
cd into the change directory into the my
ssh folder and again this is the same on
windows or mac or linux now if i list
everything in here we can see all the
the keys now i've already renamed my
private key to have the
extension.pem yours may not have that
extension but it doesn't matter whether
what the extension is and right now
we're trying to get the public key
anyways so we're going to just have to
open up this
file with the public key
now depending on your system you may be
able to use vim or some other text
editor to open up this public key i'm
just going to use vim on my system
and open up the public key and then i
can copy this public key if i go back
over to my web browser i'll just paste
it in to load it up and then i'll just
finish setting everything up here
openmetal private clouds are deployed
with openstack to three bare metal
servers
these three servers comprise the private
cloud core to open stack these three
servers are considered the control plane
private clouds are deployed with ceph
providing your cloud with shared storage
ceph is an open source software defined
storage solution and we'll be going into
more detail about ceph later in this
course now let's view the hardware
assets that were created on openmetal so
if you just created a cloud you may
already be on the cloud management page
if not if you're not on this cloud
management page you may be on this page
and you just have to click manage
now let's click assets on the left side
menu
this page contains a list of assets
included with your private cloud
deployment these include your hardware
control plane nodes and ip blocks for
inventory and also the provider ip
address blocks
the private cloud can have different
hardware based on the options you
selected in your deployment so if you're
following along you selected the same
things as me it should look pretty
similar to this so these up here these
things these three here these are three
cloud core
mb small v1 control plane nodes
and then the inventory i p address
blocks and the provider i p address
blocks with these private clouds
openstack is deployed with three
hyper-converged control plane nodes
now let's see how to access these
control pane plane nodes so these are
the nodes and you can access these
control plane nodes directly through ssh
as the root user if we go back over to
the my cloud page it gives you some
instructions on how to access so if we
go to these this access things you can
see
it gives you instructions you can see it
says two one seven two one just i wanna
show you that that's the same ip address
as the first one here two one seven two
one so when you're accessing
your your cloud you should generally
access just the first one at one of
these cloud course malls so let's go
back over here and it's gonna show us
what we need to do to
access our cloud
so we can access through the ssh key we
provided during the private cloud
deployment
so we're just going to use
this command here
you will obviously have to change the
key name and ip to match your
information but let me just copy this
and i'm going to go over to my
terminal
okay i'm in the terminal and you can see
here is the ssh command it's not the
exact same as the one we just copied
because i've updated it to have the file
name of my ssh key now yours may not say
dot p e m on the end you may just be
doing id slash rsa or underscore rsa
that's the most common way to do it so
this is basically the password to log in
to our node so i'm just going to hit
enter here
and insert the pass key
okay
we are logged in here
so we're logged in as a root
now if we go back to this page we can
see that the end goal isn't just to ssh
into our node we are actually trying to
get into the openstack dashboard
horizon is the name of the default
openstack dashboard which provides a
web-based user interface to openstack
services
it allows the users to it allows a user
to manage the cloud through a graphical
interface
so to access the new cloud's openstack
dashboard which is called horizon
we'll need to first obtain the horizons
administrator password the username by
default is admin and this is showing
right here what we need to do to get the
password to log in so after we log into
this node which we have done on our
terminal i'm going to copy this command
here
so basically this command is going to
display our password on our command line
so let's go back over to our terminal
and just paste in that command there
and now we have the keystone admin
password
so i'm just going to copy this password
here
and then if you go here it shows you
that we're going to get the keystone
admin password now that we have the
password we can launch horizon on open
metal you can click the horizon tab on
the left menu so you can see down here
i'm going to click horizon it's opening
into a new tab
and so i just opened to a new tab let me
zoom in a little quick a little bit here
and i'm going to use the username
admin
and then i'm just going to paste in the
password i just copied from the terminal
i'll click sign in
okay we're signed in to
open to horizon and it's the openstack
dashboard
now this is going to look pretty similar
no matter where you're hosting your
openstack so
we're using open metal but there's
plenty of other ways to host openstack
and
everything on horizon is going to be
basically the same no matter where
you're hosting
so the first thing we're going to learn
to do
is to create a project in openstack the
cloud is divided through the use of
projects
projects have associated with them users
who have differing levels of access
defined by roles an administrator
defines resource limits per project by
modifying quotas so let's learn how to
create a project and associate a user
with it and we'll learn how to how
project quotas can be adjusted and like
i said this interface will be similar no
matter where you deploy openstack
so there are three root level tabs let
me close so you can see we have the
project tab the admin tab and the
identity tab
only users with the with administrative
privileges can see the admin tab so some
people may just see project and identity
so to create your first project let's go
to identity and then projects
so you'll see that several projects
already exist including the admin
project
that's right here so these projects are
deployed by default and generally should
not be modified but we want to create a
new project so i'm just going to create
or click the create new project button
right here
and then we just have to fill in some
information
i'm just going to call this
deploy development
and you can see it's already giving me a
suggestion because i've tried this
before
so a description will just put
development
project
and you can basically use any name or
description
that you want so you can also add
project members or project groups but
we're not going to cover that just yet
right now i'm just going to create the
project
and
finish creating the first project so
create new project development and then
you can see it right here so once
created the project appears right in
this page
now while in this project listing page
you can view and adjust quotas for this
project as the admin user
quotas are limits on resources like the
number of instances so to view the
quotas for this project
um we're in the identity projects tab
still
so now we are going to go to this drop
down on the right so we have our project
we just developed and then i'm going to
click this drop down and go to
modify
quotas and these are all the default
quota values
so quartz also exists for the
the volume
and the network and if you set a value
to negative one that means the quota is
unlimited
we're just going to use all the default
values but it's good to know where to go
if you want to change these in the
future so i'll just click cancel we're
not going to save this
and now we're going to discuss how to
create a user and associate that user
with a project so we have the project
and we're going to associate a user so
there's already the default admin user
but now let's create a new user and log
in with that user
so first we will go to identity
users
and this only works when you're logged
in as admin or a user that has admin
privileges so i'm going to
um well well first of all you can see
that there's several users that already
listed and this is expected these are
created during the cloud deployment and
they generally should not be modified so
to create a new user we'll just click
create user
and then we can just
create we'll just put in a username
password
primary
and then we'll just fill in all this
information so username i'll put bo
you can see description is uh
optional and for user name i'll just put
boa freecodecamp.org
i'll put in my super secret password
[Music]
and then i will select a project
so i'm just going to select
development the project that we just
created
and then if we click the drop down on
roll
you can see there are several different
options and which obviously depend you
choose different roles depending on the
level of access required the default
open stack roles are this reader member
and
admin
so the reader is the
the least authoritative role in the
hierarchy
and for this example we will choose
member which is kind of like the middle
middle authority role
and then i'll just click create user
okay next we're going to log out of
horizon i'm going to click this drop
down and go to sign out
and i'm just going to log in with the
new user bo and then i'll put in the
password
and click sign in
okay we're logged in with the new user
upon logging back in
where the we're by default in the newly
created project you can see the project
we're currently on as you can see it
says development this is the project
there's only one available because we've
only created one project
now let's talk about managing and
creating images
we'll learn how to upload an image not
not a graphical image but an image as in
a copy of a linux installation so we'll
learn how to upload an image onto
openstack as well as create images out
of an
out of an existing instance
images contain a bootable operating
system that is used to create instances
you'll see that within openmiddle cloud
there are several different images that
are already available including os
debian fedora and ubuntu in addition to
this you have the option to upload
images from other sources or create your
own images we'll learn how to upload
images to glance through horizon and how
to create an image from an instant
snapshot
glance is a tool for managing instances
that allows users to discover retrieve
and regis register virtual machine
images and container images glance uses
ceph to store images instead of the
local file system to access images
within your horizon dashboard we'll
navigate to
the projects tab which we're already on
here
and then we'll go to compute
and then we will go to
images so this tab includes a list of
all the images installed on openstack
the images you see have been pre-loaded
by open metal like i said there's
already some that you can install now
these are these images aren't deployed
or anything yet they're just images you
can use if you want
so let's see how to upload your own
image if we we can do that by clicking
the create
image button
when creating an image you must choose
the format of the image
so before we start filling this all out
we are going to need an image source
we're going to need a file here
so i'm going to if you want to follow
along i'm going to leave a link in the
description to a sir os image that you
can use
i already have it downloaded so i'll be
able to select that file when we're
filling this out
so we're going to fill in the name sir
os
and then a description a ser os image
and then i'm going to browse to find the
image source
okay i'll select that for the format i'm
going to choose this qco2 dash i think
it's chemo
qemu emulator
with our configuration the this is the
recommended format qcal 2 is the most
common format for linux kvm
it expands dynamic qco2 is the most
common format for linux for linux kvm
and it expands dynamically and supports
copy on write which is all useful for
what we're doing
so i'm going to select that
and then i will just keep all these the
default settings and i'll cr click
create image
now it could take some time to complete
uploading the image
but now we're done we can actually use
this image
so next we are going to create an
instance in openstack horizon
instances or virtual machines play allow
a large role in a cloud's workload
openstack provides a way to create and
manage instances with its compute
service called nova
nova is the openstack project that
provides a way to provision compute
instances aka virtual machines novus
supports creating virtual machines bare
metal servers and has limited support
for system containers nova runs as a set
of daemons on top of existing linux
servers to provide that service
so let's see how to create an instance
and we're also going to create a private
network and router create a security
group and see how to add an ssh key pair
the first thing we'll do is learn how to
create a private network and router and
then later we'll create an instance on
this private network
so we're going to go to the project
and network
and
networks
so we're just about to create a network
but later we're going to create a router
the router is created so the private
network can be connected to your cloud's
public network allowing you to assign a
floating ip address to it making the
instance accessible over the internet
but let's create a network by clicking
the create network button
so you can basically call anything you
want we're going to use the name private
and then
we can we'll just
leave all this set to the default
options and before and now we're going
to go to the subnet tab here
and here we are going to first we're
going to create a name for our subnet
and we'll just use private
subnet
and then the network address
we have to select the private network
range so for this example just do
uh 192.168.0.1
24
and then we'll leave this as ipv4
and then the gateway ip is optional if
unset a gateway ip is selected
automatically so we'll just keep it
we'll just have it set automatically and
we're not going to disable
the gateway
and for the subnet details uh we'll just
we're not going to
change anything we're just going to keep
the default values here
then i'll click create
and then once it's created it will
appear
on this list here
okay we next need to create a router to
bridge the connections between the
private network and the public network
the public network is already here it's
called external so to create a router
let's go to
the projects and network and then
routers
and then you may be able to guess we're
just going to click create router
okay we'll set a name i'm just going to
call this router
and
we'll leave most of this to the default
values for selecting the network we're
going to choose the one we created
external
and then we're just going to click
create router
okay next we're going to connect the
router to the private network by
attaching an interface
performing this step allows network
communication between the private and
external networks
to attach an interface to the router
first we'll navigate to the list of
routers and select the one previously
created so we're actually already on the
list of routers
so i'm going to click the router
and then i'm going to go to the
interfaces tab
and then i'm going to click
add interface okay for subnet we are
going to choose the the private subnet
that we created
and if you don't set an ip address one
is selected automatically
which is what we want so i will press
submit to attach the private network to
this router
the interface is then attached and now
listed
now i'm going to show you how we can
visually see the network topology for
the network for the cloud that we've
created so i'm going to go to
project
network and then network topology
so if i scroll down here you can see
this it indicates that the external
network is connected to the private
network through the router called router
and this is what we just created so it's
like a visual
representation of everything we've done
so far
now security groups security groups
allow control of network traffic to and
from instances for example port 22 can
be opened for ssh for a single ip or a
range of ips
let's see how to create a security group
for ssh access later we'll apply the
security group we create to an instance
so i'm going to go to
project
and network
and then security groups so you should
see this single security group called
default this security group restricts
all incoming or ingress network traffic
and allows all outgoing or egress
network traffic when an instance is
created the security when an instance is
created this security group is applied
by default so to allow the network
traffic your instance requires only open
port as required to adjust the needed ip
ranges
to create a security group for ssh we
will click the create security group
button
and i'm just going to name this ssh
and then for the description you can add
something or you can just leave it blank
and then i'll click create security
group
and if you make a mistake like you
accidentally put a lowercase s instead
of an uppercase s we can go back to
security group
and then i can go to edit security group
and then we can just edit the name just
like that and then click edit security
group now i'm just going to
click manage rules here we'll go to that
page we were at before
so after creating the ssh security group
we need to add a rule allowing ssh
traffic
we'll allow ssh traffic from the first
hardware node on the cloud to this
instance
so i am going to click add rule
we'll need to obtain the ip address of
the first hardware node of the cloud
because we only want to ssh into it from
that hardware node so let's go back over
to our open metal page i'm going to go
to assets
and then i'm just going to copy the ip
address of this first hardware node now
we can film this information so for rule
we will go to ssh
and then for description i'm going to
put allows ssh
from and then just that ip address that
we just copied here
and it looks like i copied some spaces
so i'm just going to copy it again
without spaces
and for remote will leave cider
and
then i will just paste in
the ip address here
and then i'll just add this rule
okay so now we can
we can ssh
into this
network from
from this specific ip address
we now have almost everything in place
to create an instance
we'll need an ssh public key an sha and
ssh public key is required to access an
instance over ssh the key is injected
into the instance when created
we actually have already done this in
this course because we needed an ssh
public key
in order to basically get this whole
thing started that's how we were able to
ssh
into our node earlier
like i said the key is injected into the
instance when it's created so what we're
doing is we're creating an instance that
can be accessed over ssh from one of the
cloud hardware nodes so we'll have to
create an ssh key pair
in one of the hardware nodes
the public portion of that key pair is
associated with the instance we'll
create soon
okay i'm back at the terminal i'm still
logged into the hardware node where i
got the password the admin password we
used previously
so if you're not logged into the
hardware node you should log in again
just like we did before
and now we're going to create an ssh key
pair
and i'm just going to use the ssh keygen
and
this time i am going to make a pair of
size 4096 bits so i'm going to do the
dash b and then the number of bits 4096
and then i'm going to just press enter
and i'll just use these default values
if you've already created before like i
have you can just override it but you
probably won't have to because it will
probably the first time
and i'll create a passphrase
okay now i just have to get access to
the public key that we just created so
i'll do cat
root
so here's the directory that i got
stored in and the file name is id
underscore rsa.pub
okay so this is the public key i'm just
going to select all of this
and copy it
now now that we have the ssh key for the
instance we're going to create the
instance that can be accessed over ssh
from the cloud's hardware node
so to do that i am going to go to
projects
then
compute
then
instances
and then
launch instance so there's a bunch of
tabs here we're not going to go through
all of them but we're going to go
through a lot of them
some of them will just keep the default
values so i'm going to create an
instance name for this example i'm just
going to use jump station you can call
it anything you like and then you can
optionally put a description i'm just
going to keep the rest of these to their
default settings and then i'm going to
go to
source
now i'm going to make sure it's an image
that we're booting from an image
and i'm just going to keep all these
default we are going to create a new
volume
now we have to choose which
which image that we're going to use so
for this example we're not even going to
use the image we're not going to use the
image that we uploaded we're going to
use synth os 8. so we'll use the centos
stream
and i'm just going to click this up
arrow
and it's going to bring it right up into
this allocated section so this is
showing that we are going to be using
the scent os 8 for the image on this
instance
now i'm going to go to the next tab
flavor
and this is all about defining vcpus ram
and disk space used by an instance
so there's a bunch of pre-built flavors
and
the one we're going to use is just
called m1 small so i'm going to scroll
down a little bit in one small and then
click the up arrow here
and it's going to have a set amount of
ram disk space root disks
and um
next
yeah so
this is what we're going to use for the
flavor now we're going to go to networks
now i'm going to bring up the the
private network the one that we created
uh these provide the communication
channels for instance for instances in
the cloud
and you can choose to add the external
network as well
but it's not really recommended it's
better to use floating i a floating ip
if your instance is going to require
internet connectivity
you should only expose portions of your
network as necessary this reduces the
attack surface and improves the
application security if a private
network is not created in an instance is
created in a default cloud it's
associated with the external network
this means that the instance consumes a
public ip and it could be reached over
the internet
so next we're going to skip over network
ports and go straight to security groups
and we're going to bring up the security
group that we previously created the ssh
one
and then we are going to move to
key pair
you can upload your key at the stage
using the form using the
import key pair here
you can also create a key pair on this
tab
we already created the pair earlier from
the first hardware node in the cloud
so
we are going to just use the the key
that we already created so we're going
to click import key pair
and then i'm going to just name this
jump station key
and the key type is going to be ssh key
and then you can either choose the file
the key or i can just paste it in here
remember we copied it from our terminal
and then i'll just click import key pair
once the public key is imported we'll
create the instance by pressing launch
instance
the other tabs are just outside the
scope of this demonstration here
so the instance is going to go through a
build process
so you may have to allow a few minutes
for this to occur
and when complete the instance will
appear in the instance listings page
well i guess it's already appearing here
it's just not it's still
spawning as it says here and now it's
complete it's done the instance has been
created
now we are going to assign and attach
floating ips
basically an ip that people can access
to get to this instance
the only way to connect to the instance
is by exposing it via the floating ip or
another instance in the same network i'm
just about to show you how to allocate a
floating ip and attach it to this
instance
so we're going to start by going to
project here
and then we're going to go to the
network tab
and then floating ips
and then allocate ip to project
we'll make sure the pool is set to
external
and then we can add a description if we
want it's even it's optional you don't
even have to and then click allocate ip
now we want to allocate the ip to the
jumpstation instance by clicking this
associate button here
so we have the ip address already filled
in here and we'll select the port and
the port will click the port that we
called jumpstation
and then click associate
so this instance is now available over
ssh from the first hardware node in the
cloud
so let's try
logging in to the instance
so first of all i'm going to copy this
ip address
and then i'm going to go back over to
the terminal we're already logged into
the hardware node if you're not anymore
you can re-log into the hardware node
over ssh and then we are going to ssh
into the instance we just created so
i'll do ssh dash i
and now i'm going to put in the path to
the private key that we created
and this private key is basically like
the password to log into this instance
so it's root slash dot ssh slash
id underscore
rsa and then i'm going to put in the ip
address oh but first actually before the
ip address that we copied earlier i have
to put in the username which is going to
be sent os because that's just the
default username
of the
operating system we installed on this
instance okay now i'm going to press
enter here and then it's going to see if
i ask if i want to continue connecting
yes
and now i can enter the passphrase that
we created that i created when i
developed the
the private key pair the public pirate
key pairs so put in the passphrase
and logged in
great
in the next section we'll do something
while logged into the machine
but for now let's go back over to the
openstack web interface
so far we've been learning how to manage
openstack through a web browser that's
this one right here
but it's also possible to manage through
the command line using openstack's cli
called openstack client using the
command line to manage your cloud
introduces more flexibility in
automation tasks and can generally make
an administrator's life simpler
so let's learn how to get that installed
we'll install the openstack client cli
on the instance we just created that we
named jumpstation
before installing openstack cli you must
obtain two files from horizon which are
required to prepare your shell
environment so let me show you how to
get those files and talk more about them
i'm going to click where it says api
access right here and if i click down
here
it's going to show two different files
that we can download
and we need to download both of them the
openstack the clouds.yaml file
and the rc file
clouds.yaml is used as a source of
configuration for how to connect to a
cloud and then the openstack rc file is
used as a source of authentication for
the user and project
and so i've now downloaded both of those
files
and now we need to prepare and install
openset client
so i'm going to go back over to the
terminal
and
i'm still logged in to the instance the
instance we created previously
so
let's go through the steps to prepare
and install the openstack client
so first we need to prepare the
clouds.yaml so first we need to get the
files that we downloaded pre just now
onto our local machine we need to
transfer them to this instance
so let me show you how to do that first
we're going to get the clouds.yaml file
over to this instance i'm going to start
by making a directory honor instance so
make directory
and i'm going to call this it's where
the directory is going to be slash dot
config slash open stack
now that i've created the directory
so i'm going to create and open a blank
clouds.yaml file i'm going to use the v
editor so if i use the v command and i
put in a file name it will open a file
to start editing and if the file doesn't
already exist it will create that file
so i'm going to navigate to the
directory that we just created
and then i'm going to call this
clouds.yaml
okay now we have to get the contents
from the cloud.yaml file on our local
computer into this instance so basically
we're going to open up clouds.yaml in a
text editor on our local computer
okay so i got clouds.yaml open i'm just
going to copy this this is just in
sublime text on my local computer you
can open up up in any text editor now
i'm going to go back to the the v or
vitex editor on the instance and i'm
just going to paste in the contents of
the file now to save it i'm going to hit
the escape key then i'm going to hit the
colon key and then wq w for write or
save and q for quit
okay so i just saved the the clouds.yaml
file onto here
and now we are going to do the same
thing with the openstack rc file oh and
by the way the clouds.yaml file can
actually be saved in a few different
locations but the one we saved in is a
is a common place to save the file
so the
the openstack rc file it doesn't really
matter where you save the file so i'm
just going to
save it um basically right where we're
at right now so i'm going to do
v
and then i'm just going to call the make
i'm going to create and start editing a
file called development
[Music]
dash open
rc.sh
this is going to be
a shell file that we can run it'll allow
us to run commands
now i'm going to open that file on the
local machine
okay so i'm just going to cop or select
all the file copy
and go back to the instance here and
just just paste in
the contents of the file and again i'm
going to press escape then colon then wq
and that's going to save and exit the
file now we'll source the development
openrc file which will allow us to run
openstack commands and i'll have to put
in my openstack password
now we are going to create a python
virtual environment we're going to
create the virtual environment so we
don't interfere with the system's python
version
in the default synth os 8 stream
installation the systems the systems
python execute executable is called
platform python so we're going to use
that to create the virtual environment
so let me show you first we have to
access we have to put in the directory
where the the python version is on this
instance which is that at this um
at this
spot on the computer lib exec slash
platform dash python
and then
we have to v e and v is how we're going
to create the virtual environment and
we're going to create the virtual
environment at this directory at this
path slash v e and v
okay uh we created that and now i just
need to activate the python virtual
environment so i'm gonna do source
and then v e and v
slash
ben
slash activate
okay we know we're activated because we
have this this is the name of the
virtual what we call we this is the name
of the virtual environment right here
next we need to upgrade pip
pip is used to install
um different python packages on the
instance so i'm gonna upgrade pip with
the command pip up
pip install
upgrade
pip
okay now we need to install openstack
client which is what we've been
working toward this whole time
so
there's
two openstack packages
but the one that
is kind of maintained more is called
python-openstack client so we're going
to do pip install
python
dash
open stack
client
okay we now have the openstack cli
installed on our instance
so there's quite a few things you can do
with this cli
we're not really going to
cover
all of them or very much but i'm going
to just show you a few things like
one like for an initial command we can
list the servers associated with the
project so i can do open stack
that's how we start the openstack cli
and i'm going to put server
list
okay and actually i'm going to zoom out
so this
looks better
[Music]
let's zoom out quite a bit for this to
okay there we go
so we can see we just have
one server this is the one we create
jump station we call it jump station
remember we chose an m1 dot small
for the flavor
and so this is basically the server that
we previously created i'm just going to
zoom in again here
and when using the openstack client
there is typically a common command
pattern for what you want to accomplish
all openstack commands begin with
openstack
you can execute openstack by itself to
enter into a shell where commands no
longer need to be prefixed by openstack
so i can just type in openstack
and now we can type in any command
so we can do the server list
and it's going to basically show this
the same thing from before
i'm not going to zoom out again so you
can see what i'm typing in a little more
but let's go out of this
and now i'm just going to run openstack
from the command line again and if you
use open
stack
help
then we can list all available sub
commands
initially see all the flags that you can
pass but after scrolling a bit
uh you'll see that the command list will
start here
so these are all the the commands that
we can we can use
and i'll just quit out of that before we
see all of them because there's quite a
few uh if you see after you see the
available commands you can learn more
about a command just using
openstack help this is like a lot of
clis we can just do openstack help and
let's say we want to know about the
server command open
so if we do that
then it's going to show the different
commands we can use
with openstack server so these are all
the things that we can do with
a server
it's very common when using openset
client to list items and the command
format
is typically the openstack sub command
list so
for instance we can do
opens
openstack server list
and so that's gonna list the servers
just like we had shown before
you can also get more information about
an item by
using the show command so
let me give you an example we can do
open stack
server
show
jump station
so the the name of the server
and here we're going to show details
about the server
so there's quite a bit more you can do
with the openstack open stack cli
administrators generally use the cli if
they need complex options as they may
not be available through the graphic
user interface but that's basically all
we're going to talk about in this course
if you're interested in any particular
thing you can just look up the
documentation to figure out how to do
what you want to do in the cli
so now we're going to talk about how
private clouds are deployed we're going
to learn more about how your private
cloud is deployed and learn more about
the environment
openstack can be deployed in several
different ways and this section
highlights the characteristics of this
private cloud we're going to explain
some of the advantages of this type of
deployment and some things that are
unique to open metal
let's talk more about the
containerization of openstack like i
mentioned open metal uses cola ansible
and it uses it to set up docker
containers for running services so if
you need to make any configuration
changes to your nodes cola ansible
should be used to push those changes if
it's not used then there's a risk of the
changes being reverted during the system
updates some advantages of
containerization through docker are that
the containers create an isolated
environment reducing software
dependencies containers can be scaled
and allow for services to balance across
your cluster
containers provide increased flexibility
for test releases patches and automation
and containers have a consistent and
repeatable deployment and a shorter
initialization time in openmetal disk
storage is provided through ceph
ceph is an object storage interface that
can provide interfaces for multiple
different storage types on a single
cluster and openmetal ceph is comprised
of two elements object storage and block
storage
the ceph object storage utilizes the
stuff object storage gateway daemon with
open metal clouds ceph's rgw replaces
swift so there is no docker container
for swift instead swift endpoints are
connected directly to the rgw
authentication for rgw is handled
through keystone
seth block storage connects to the
sender service utilizing ceph's rados
block device within the cloud these
objects are stored in cephpools seth
provides a layer of abstraction that
allows objects to be recognized as
blocks
some advantages of using ceph are data
is self-healing and will will
redistribute data across your cluster in
the event of power hardware or
connectivity issues also data is
replicated and highly available
and seth has the ability to run on
common commodity hardware and to mix
hardware from different vendors
ceph was selected as the storage
solution for private cloud core
openstack clouds due to its ability to
store data in a replicated fashion the
data stored in the ceph cluster is
accessible from any of your cloud's
control plane nodes the storage is
considered shared across all nodes which
can make recovering an instance and its
data trivial so let's learn how to check
the status of your ceph cluster and see
available disk usage using the command
line
so first let's make sure we're logged
into the clouds one of the cloud control
plane nodes not an instance so if you're
logged into the instance before you have
to log out one layer to the control
plane node but not log out so far that
you're on your local computer so to
check the status of the ceph cluster we
can use ceph status so i'll just do ceph
status
and then we can get a lot of information
about um
how like like we can get the uses
information number of objects the number
of pools and stuff like that
and to check the available disk space in
your ceph cluster we can use seth
df
and we can see that how much we have
available how much has been used and a
lot of information about the various
pools
now let's look at how to find the
resource usage of the private cloud
we'll explore how to utilize the horizon
dashboard to determine the total memory
and compute usage for a project
as well as how to view instances stored
on each node then we'll look at disk
usage by explaining how to briefly
interact with the cloud's ceph cluster
using the command line and finally we'll
go over adding and removing nodes from
the ceph cluster
there are currently three variations to
private cloud deployments small standard
and large
all private cloud deployments have a
cluster of three hyper-converged servers
but will have different allocations of
memory storage and cpu processing power
depending on the configuration and
hardware in addition you have the option
of adding additional hardware nodes to
the cluster
so
let's view the resources used by the
cloud
we have to be logged in as the admin
user so i'm going to sign out
and then i'm going to login as admin if
you remember to get the password we
actually have to log in with our command
with the command line so let's go over
to the command line and we're already
logged in so i am going to use this
line right here grep keystone admin
password and then the
path
and then we can get the admin password
you can always change this if you want
to make it uh something
that's different than that but i'll sign
in here
so once we're in the admin project i'm
going to navigate to
admin
compute
hypervisors
and this is going to
show a few items the
vcpu usage
the memory usage and the local disk
usage
there's also an option to see the
location of your instances within your
cluster
to view this information we'll go to the
admin compute
instances here
and then you have the option
to see the the project
the host
as well as ip addresses
and the status
and
just a bunch of other or in the power
state and just a bunch of other things
here
to access information require regarding
your ceph clusters resource pools you'll
need to use ceph's cli
so let's go back over to the terminal
and
let's just do some common
useful resource monitoring and health
commands so to check the status of staff
we'll just do ceph
dash s
and so this is just a shortened version
of one of the commands we used earlier
and then you can do ceph
df
and again this is one that we've already
covered but some new ones would be ceph
health
detail
[Music]
health okay and another one is ceph
osd
pool ls
so lis this pools and we can add the
detail like we can put
images for additional this will give us
additional details regarding replication
and health metrics
we've reached the end of this course
you now know the basics of openstack now
there's a lot more you can do with
openstack but you should know enough now
to start learning more on your own
well thanks for watching